j'ai pensé qu'il serait sans doute utile
que dans notre arsenal législatif
il existe une structure du compagnonnage
parfaitement différencier du mariage
c'est pas un sou mariage évidemment ça
n'en a ni le caractère rituel nil
caractère symbolique ça n'ouvre pas
droit évidemment à l'adoption ni à la
procréation médicalement assistée
mais ça exprime entre deux personnes 1
une idée solidarité globale
alors bon le projet est arrivé à
l'assemblée nationale j'ai vu que ce qui
nous était proposé était largement
similaire aux préconisations que j'avais
fait il y à déjà bien des années
j'ai donc considéré en conscience qu' il
n'était pas utile d'avoir sur cette
affaire une petite strictement
politiciennes ou politicarde mais de
juger selon ma conscience